someone wrote Into My Show said Michael
if you could meet the devil I said I
don't know I probably haven't met the
devil a few times don't don't wish I met
him twice you've met him personally
how'd that go
not well the first time because I was I
wasn't even a seminary and I was
discerning I just came out of my life of
sin
um I had a I've joined Our Lady of
Victory like I mentioned and this little
old
um polish priest who became my spiritual
director and um I remember one day I
went in and I said you know this job is
killing me because well I did it was a
sales position I was entertaining big
shots at all fancy restaurants every
night drinking drinking drinking I said
I I can't balance this with trying to
live this new life it's not working
so he said to me well let's do this why
don't you um for the next month
uh you can go call ahead or go to go to
the meet to the restaurant early and
tell the bartender when you order a
drink that it would be just club soda
novaka but you would order it publicly
and then they won't know I said I could
do that so he said no alcohol for a
month
so it's the middle of the day it's like
noon I come out of the church
and there's this again this beautiful
handsome man
custom tailored suit
he's staring at me
which if you've ever lived in New York
you don't stare at people it's pretty
unusual very like you put your you don't
yeah it's it's almost an attack like
this I'm being attacked now I have to
fight and I just was like weird so I
turned to walk towards my office
and he runs up next to me and he grabs
me by the arm
again no guys do that no guy grabs
Somebody by the arm and it's like
escorting them and he goes let's get a
drink
and I just had chills go up and down my
body
and I said get away from me and then I
turned Direction and went towards my
apartment because it was closer
and I got to my apartment and I walked
through the doors and the doors closed
behind me I looked out and he was just
laughing at me
and it was like
so he leaves and I run back to the
church I go father let me tell you what
just happened
what do you think happened here what is
this he goes I told you you're going to
have a Target on your back so you got to
be careful
and I said was that who I think it was
and he goes
sounds like it certainly it seems that
way I mean that was just no random
person for sure
so that that and that really
it's frightening me to be honest I was
like that I didn't sign up for this at
all
and then a few years later
I was on a vacation visiting an old
Banker friend down in Miami
and uh
she set up a whole luncheon at this
place called Nikki Beach which really
isn't appropriate for
seminarians or priests it's very again
it's the glitterati the high-powered
wealthy people it's bottle service on
the beach right right and I'm just like
oh this is I don't know how I feel about
this
and the the two girls to my right I knew
both Sandra was hosting and my ex-boss
um Christine is with me and they start
looking at this guy across over by the
other end of the deck
like oh my God look at that guy he's so
handsome he's beautiful and all of a
sudden Santa's like oh he's coming over
here
and I turn and I look and it's him
it's it's the it's the wine they wanted
to get the drink
only now he's like shirtless in a
bathing suit and he walks up and he goes
what are you doing here I thought you
were going to be a priest
and he goes this is my territory you
shouldn't be here
and both the girls got flipped out they
were like they had the scare mechanism
like the face that I'm making right now
yeah literally like you know
danger Will Robinson and Christine's
like get the check and she threw money
down she's like we're out of here and we
left
but like when those things happen God
allowed it right so for me I felt like I
wasn't supposed to be there and God was
letting me know you have no place going
to places like that anymore don't do
that again right the devil whether he
wants to be or not it can be a tool of
absolutely absolutely he's not more
powerful than guys he's nowhere near as
powerful as God and his uh his own will
will be foiled in God's Providence
ultimately but
and the fact that you you had these
friends there who saw it who reacted
that way who can attest to it it wasn't
just you had a Daydream or something no
they they were visibly shaken
and to this day they talk about it and
they get spooked to stock about it
I I don't know when I say maybe I've met
the devil I mean you know I've engaged
in all sorts of sins I don't know that
I've ever actually met the devil I but
I'm pretty convinced I've met angels I'm
I'm quite convinced of that and uh
also in New York there's a lot New York
is a spiritually Rich place I guess but
improbable kinds of meetings of Str
again and New York strangers don't come
up to you they don't look at you they
don't striking up conversations
in the strangest of places I mean I what
I sometimes fear when I tell these
stories that it's like when you wake up
and you tell your wife about the dream
you just had she goes back to sleep
before you get the first sentence out
because it's so boring it's very
interesting to the people who have the
experiences but you know unless there is
shocking as as your two with the old
devil but when those experiences happen
you meet someone strike up a
conversation there's one guy all right
I'll get into it there's one guy
I was really down in the dumps I was
working in politics and show business as
I guess I still am and but you know I
was just right out of college I was I
was I was back in this
re reversion moment it was really
spiritually written there's a lot of
Temptation and sin and there was a lot
of shocking Grace and kind of numerous
experience and but I was kind of down in
the dumps because I'm just kind of I'm
not doing great in my career I just got
out of school I don't I went from being
the Big Man on Campus to being some
nobody guy in New York and
I'm on the subway on on the sixth train
and I I forget exactly which direction
it was but it was
either I got on or either this happened
at 28th Street going uptown or 33rd
Street going downtown okay and I'm on
the train
and this kind of funny looking black guy
and this lady walk onto the train and
they're clearly together
they go you know she's standing over
here and then this guy sits down right
next to me and I'm just trying to read
my Kindle so he's just looking at me
just looking at me
says hey
who are you
it's like huh oh I'm Michael he was like
oh my name's Michael too oh we're angels
I said I just I had just come back into
leaving in God and the church and
everything I said oh yeah how about that
he goes
yes
so what do you do I said oh
you know I work in politics and show
business or so you know essentially
unemployed you know that's not that's
not the I said I'm not I'm not doing
very much yeah
don't worry about that you'll be great
train comes to a stop he stands up walks
off the train doesn't even look at the
woman he walked on the train with and
the the thing that's so weird about this
and you will know this as a New Yorker
is on that train
28th Street to 33rd Street it's five
blocks yeah nobody in New York
is going to take the subway to go from
28th Street to 33rd Street to 33rd
Street to 28th Street nobody's going to
take this trip and go five yeah you
would take it to go 33rd Street to
Brooklyn Bridge yeah you would take it
but no that's that's one of the shortest
intervals probably maybe the shortest in
the New York City Subways no one's doing
that and I thought look it's such a
minor trivia but I can't it's a good
point though
I couldn't explain it and I thought and
then I just thought
what does that mean what does that mean
what am I supposed to take from that
little support that's what I took from
it all I thought was just God's saying
we'll shout out hey I'm here I'm here
you know it's just sort of like hey
buddy boo you know yeah I'll tell you
something though about people who
believe people who don't believe
um
I think if you go through life when
these little things happen believing for
the most part believe everything right
yeah what's the harm is it going to harm
you no
but it actually makes you live a more
uplifted
happy life
and somebody who goes to the holy
believing nothing
because that's a horrible way to live to
believe nothing is happening
it's almost like
um there's two strains of thought about
how you interact with the world
especially in New York you can believe
everybody's out to get you
and occasionally somebody's nice or you
can believe everybody's basically nice
and occasionally they fail you yeah it's
so much better to live thinking
everybody's basically pretty good and
one or two people are going to get you
and it's okay I'll deal with it yeah but
to think everybody is out to get you
then every moment of your life isn't it
is in defense and attack mode
that's no way to live yeah
I know people that their marriages are
like that like they're in a marriage
where they feel like they're in a battle
all the time and I'm like yeah it's not
gonna you're not gonna make it you can't
go that long in that really kind of a
stressful Zone without somebody giving
up